Deadpool 2 just hit us with a new trailer
stuffed with Marvel in-jokes, easter eggs,
some Justice League and Wolverine Origins
shade, plus a look at Cable in action as well
as some other new characters we're getting
in the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm combing through the Deadpool
2 trailer for easter eggs, gags and other
details you might have missed!
If you're new to my channel I do regular comic-book
movie videos, and I'm kicking off a Deadpool
giveaway for all my subscribers.
Just leave me a comment about the trailer
and make sure you're subscribed for a chance
to win!
And don't forget to listen out for the winner
of my Ant-Man & The Wasp giveaway later in
this video.
The trailer begins with hints at some of Cable's
origin story.
"I was born into war."
"Bred into it."
"People think they understand pain."
"But they have no concept of it."
"What's the most pain you've ever felt?"
"Maybe the kind that leaves you more machine
than man."
In the comics, Cable is the son of Cyclops
and the Jean Grey-clone Madelyne Prior who
was created by Mr Sinister whose wish was
to use their child as a weapon.
And the
teddy bear on Cable's belt could be a tease
to Hope Summers, a mutant child who in the
comics Cable believed to be the Mutant Messiah
who would save both mutants and non-mutants
alike.
There was also a "Hope" easter egg in the
Deadpool short "No Good Deed".
I also liked how Cable's gun goes up to eleven
in a hat tip to Spinal Tap's amplifiers which
could be dialled up to eleven.
Then of course we get our first fourth-wall
break in the trailer when Deadpool interrupts
to point out Cable's still wearing a green
sleeve in the footage.
"Wait, no stop!"
"What in the actual ass?!"
"Dale!
What?!
Why?!"
"Why are the visual effects not done?"
"It's a metal arm!
It's not like we're trying to remove a moustache."
The moustache line is an amusing dig at DC's
Justice League and the problems that movie
had trying to digitally erase Henry Cavill's
moustache which he had to keep during the
Justice League's reshoots due to his contract
for filming Mission: Impossible 6.
On top of that, the fact this early Cable
footage is missing the completed CGI is also
a call-back to the movie X-Men Origins: Wolverine,
which featured Ryan Reynolds as Wade Wilson
aka Deadpool.
An unfinished copy of that particular Wolverine
movie, which lacked many of the necessary
visual effects, leaked online a month before
the final film was released in cinemas in
2009.
Back in the trailer the Merc with a Mouth
finishes his CGI rant with the line "F***
it, I'll do it myself!"
Deadpool's words are a nice reference to the
Marvel character Thanos and the end of Avengers:
Age of Ultron where Thanos says "Fine, I'll
do it myself."
Actor Josh Brolin, of course, plays Cable
in Deadpool 2, as well as Thanos in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
But that's not the end of this trailer's Thanos
easter eggs and jokes.
For example, when Sheriff Deadpool says "I
got the stones to help you" to Cable, it's
a play on words to do with the fact that Thanos
has long been on the hunt for the Infinity
Stones in the MCU, a mission we'll see him
continue in Avengers: Infinity War.
Sheriff Deadpool also tells Cable, 'You know,
you're a lot taller in the ...', but he gets
interrupted.
Perhaps the sentence was meant to finish with
the words, 'in the comics' because, unlike
these toys here, in the books, Cable is taller
than Deadpool.
It could also be a dig at the fact that, in
real life, Josh Brolin is shorter than Ryan
Reynolds.
Likewise, it could be another hint at Brolin's
big-screen comic-book role as Thanos, who,
like Cable, is also very tall.
Pixar's Toy Story movies get a big old shout-out
as the toy version of Deadpool not only uses
one of Woody's lines, Reach for the sky!',
but he's also dressed like the much-loved
toy, with a yellow shirt and white buttons,
black and white waistcoat, sheriff's badge,
brown hat, and red neckerchief.
Notice also how Wade, the name of Deadpool's
alter ego, is inked on the right sole of the
toys' shoes, in a clear a nod to the way Andy
wrote his name on the soles of his toys including
Woody.
Also, the 'E' in Wade is inverted, in a similar
fashion to how the 'N' in Andy is reversed
in the Toy Story movies.
And did you catch those green toy soldiers
too who also make an appearance in the Toy
Story films.
Plus, here in the background is Deadpool's
painting from his earlier Wet on Wet teaser.
So, now we get to the meat of the trailer
with Cable lining up against a bunch of DMC
security guards.
The DMC appear to be the movie version of
the Mutant Response Division, aka MRD, which
have appeared on TV and in the comics as an
anti-mutant elite military group that's captured
and attempted to contain mutants in the Marvel
universe.
Notice how the style of helmet and uniform
does have some similarities to those of the
MRD.
We also get to see Cable and Deadpool in action
around a DMC truck which appears to have some
yellow-suited prisoners on board.
Judging by the electronic restrainers around
their necks, I suspect they may be mutants
that have been imprisoned by the DMC.
We also get a quick look at Julian Dennison's
character who looks like he's an, as-yet,
unnamed mutant.
You might have seen Dennison in director Taika
Waititi's Hunt for the Wilderpeople, but he
also appeared in a quick shot in the teaser
which hinted at some possible fire-based powers
for his character.
By the way, I think that might also be a toy
of him earlier in Deadpool's Toy Story-inspired
set.
Another shot also suggests that Wade Wilson
either gets captured at some point by the
DMC or he goes undercover as he's wearing
a yellow uniform plus neck restrainer in this
shot of him in prison.
There's also what looks like another set of
villains who may or may not be linked to the
DMC.
Deadpool and Domino go up against some staff
in white uniforms and there are some interesting
banners in the background which read "Purity
Humanity Infinity" and "Clean Blood Pure Hearts".
This might be a link to The Purifiers who
were another anti-mutant group from the comics.
The Purifiers were set up by the fanatical
X-Men hater William Stryker and became a quasi-religious
organisation that carried out terrorist attacks
on the mutant population and the X-Men.
They may also tie in to Cable's storyline
in the movie as Cable comes from the future
and in the comics has links to the cult-like
Clan Askani.
The "Purity Humanity Infinity" banner also
showed up in the Wet on Wet teaser and in
this shot there's also a "The End Is Near"
banner with a picture of a man with an X-logo
plus a cybernetic arm, which could indicate
that it's Cable.
We also get a brief shot of some other new
Deadpool characters.
On the right is actor Terry Crews from Brooklyn
Nine-Nine, but at the moment we don't know
for sure what character he's playing in the
film.
Possibilities include G.W.
Bridge, Hammer or perhaps another character
who'll appear in a future X-Force movie.
And just behind Deadpool and Crews is someone
who looks like the comic book character Shatterstar
who became part of the X-Force and who seems
to be wearing a similar type of headpiece
as he did in the comics.
There's also a mystery character loading up
a gun who's wearing some very curious skull
rings on their hand.
If you've got any thoughts or theories on
who this might be, let me know in the comments
below.
And if you're wondering where Colossus went,
well, he didn't turn up in the main trailer,
but there's an extra scene in an international
trailer which looks like it's in the X-Mansion
and shows Wade grabbing Colossus's butt.
And there's a painting of Karl Marx on the
stairway behind them.
So, did you spot any other cool easter eggs
or in-jokes in the new Deadpool 2 trailer?
And have you got any theories on what Deadpool
and Cable are going to get up to in the movie?
Be sure to comment about the trailer and subscribe
for a chance to win an awesome Deadpool Funko
Pop.
And if you enjoyed this, do like and share
the video, and remember to turn on your notifications!
The winner of my Ant-Man and the Wasp giveaway
is on screen right now, so if that's you make
sure you private message me with your details.
You can check out more of my Marvel and superhero
videos you might like by tapping the screen
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!